this one is the guide for Gulf War
veterans these are the Veterans Health
Initiative clinicians in the VA are
supposed to read this to understand what
are the exposures of Gulf War veterans
there's nothing in this document that
reflects the science that we know today
this is all information from 1999 and
back it's the stress theory and it needs
to be updated because if the clinicians
in the VA don't know what the illnesses
are they don't know what the exposures
are they can't possibly come up with
treatments or give the veterans the kind
of care they need I would encourage the
committee to please ask the VA to update
this and I submit the rest of my
statement for the record thank you very
much mr. Robinson and thanks to all the
panelists and we'll start with Mr
Sanders we're going to do ten minute
question so we can get a little more
depth here oh thanks Thank You mr.
chairman Chris Shay's and I have
participated in dozens and dozens of
hours of hearings and I have to say that
this is the most peculiar process that
I've ever seen in my life something
something is wrong here we have evidence
that over twenty six percent of Gulf War
vets were made casualties that's
probably the largest number in any war
on history dr. Hall tells us that he
recently went to a meeting and that over
90 92 people were present who had
identical physical symptoms I have
talked to Gulf War veterans in the state
of Vermont around the room where they
tell me when they walk into a grocery
store and they smell detergents or
perfume they get sick we have heard
Chris and I have heard people come
forward here with terrible terrible
illnesses that's one reality that
crochets and I and other members of this
committee have heard for years and then
there's another reality that seems to
come from the officials is we have heard
today from dr. Heinrich that a they have
80,000 reported 80,000 soldiers have
reported symptoms significantly less
than the number the mists
Binns made but number two we have 241
federally funded projects spending 247
million dollars dr. Heinrich is there a
Gulf War illness the experts that we
spoke with sir have said that there is
unusual symptoms and that they still
cannot identify the cause but it's also
clear to us that they are doing studies
to try to further identify what that
might be thank you that's it that's the
insanity that we're dealing with 247
million dollars and your researchers
have come up with the fact that there
are symptoms hey you could have saved a
lot of money crochets and I knew that
they were symptoms mr. bunk are their
symptoms store Albertson are their
symptoms absolutely good we don't have
to pay them 247 million dollars so what
are we doing I have concluded and I
don't mean this to be a mean statement
to the to the members of the DoD because
I know in their hearts they certainly
want all veterans to get a fair shake
and to be well but something very
strange is going on I do not know why
from day one the DoD to a lesser degree
the VA but both institutions have been
resistant to the very serious crisis
that we are facing and the pain that is
going on and I would agree for a stock
with mr. Blanco who made a very simple
statement and he said we should get the
research money out of the VA and the DoD
I think that's right now let me ask
again dr. Heinrich a very simple
question I want to get to mr. Binns dr.
Haley who was a researcher who's be
testifying later on this is what he says
in his report that he's going to tell us
later he says quote I am encouraged at
the progress that has been made in
understanding the new type of brain cell
damage that appears to underlie Gulf War
veterans symptoms end of quote is he
crazy he's been saying this for years
what do you say and he hasn't spent 243
million dollars is he right is he wrong
he's right what what we have seen and
what experts have said to us is that
there are concerns that there is
neurological damage and I think that
that's one reason you'll hear the VA
talk about new efforts to fund studies
that are really focusing on neuro
degeneration he has gone beyond concerns
that there may be neurological damage
he's gone a lot further than that and it
is incredible to me and to the taxpayers
of this country and all of the people
are concerned about our veterans that
the VA and the DoD have done so very
little mr. Binns I want to thank you I
mean I know I'm not a great fan of
President Bush let me tell you that but
I think that in pointing you and an
Anthony Principia we have some serious
people who are trying to deal with this
issue from your point of view give us
some understanding of why the government
has been so lacks in coming up with an
understanding of the cause or some kind
of treatment despite their not
insignificant sum of money where do you
think we should be going from here yeah
I can't answer the question of why they
haven't gotten with the program how
would you assess 243 million dollars
being spent with the results that we've
seen the program has been a lot of the
money has been spent in areas which at
least today we can conclude and earlier
you might have been prepared to conclude
we're not the areas that would lead to
the most promising answers for example
as recently as 2003 the VA budget in
that year according to the recent report
to Congress provided for about 4.1
million dollars in Gulf War illnesses
research of that amount 57% went to
study stress and other psychological
causes seventeen percent went to study
things like web based training for VA
physicians on bioterrorism events so
only seventeen percent actually
for things that we believe are directly
related we don't have a lot of fun she
looks you I don't mean to be rude okay
based on all of the evidence do you
agree or disagree with mr. Blanco who
basically is saying look we need
research these guys are not going to do
it we should get out of the VA in the
DoD I would have agreed with you four
months ago but secretary Princip II as
I'm sure the representatives here from
VA will attest is very concerned about
this issue I wish I could guarantee that
secretary Principia would be the
Secretary of Veterans Affairs for the
next 20 years or so we are going to have
a good program that is very accelerated
coming out of va whether it can continue
and whether there is a sustained effort
depends upon many factors as you well
know so I think if you want a guarantee
that there will be this kind of effort
both from VA and DOD Congress would need
to make it a line-item budget that there
be Gulf War illnesses are you see if you
could appreciate the frustration that we
we feel 243 million dollars is not an
insignificant sum of money and the
question is you heard from dr. Heinrich
basically they've done very little with
this money so I think the question is
not that they should not be money but
should we be saying look for whatever
reason the DoD is certainly not going to
do it maybe the VA will do something but
we've got to get out of Capitol Hill and
stuff finding serious researchers in the
private sector who by the way if i'm not
mistaken army to be personally but i
think you came into this issue out of
family issues because you saw her
correlation between a family member and
the illness that our veterans was seeing
is that correct yes and i think that
you're right in saying that there needs
to be a mix i believe of VA and outside
research the limitation of VA research
is that they can only fund VA physicians
obviously that is where the veterans are
so there should be a substantial
investment there and as i said i believe
they're about to do that on the other
hand you need to have I don't know who
is the one to do it NIH or deity but you
need to have some agency with the
capability of funding
best talent available outside of the
federal government and you need to have
a total funding commitment that is at
least the level of the historical levels
of commitment because this time I'm
naive perhaps but I believe that at
least it's happening at VA and I think I
see it happening in other agencies as
well I don't believe it will be wasted
and your judgment is dr. he'll be making
some important breakthroughs dr. Haley
has been the guy out there with the
spear advancing on this this evil for
many many years he's made continued
advances today I would say he's got
squads of troops behind him and he's got
other people in the in the woods that
you'll be hearing from later on who
really represent the heavy artillery
that are willing to come into this data
area that was Jim how am i doing on time
of my say another minute and a half okay
let me say I mean there's some good news
is that some breakthroughs are being
made unfortunately they have not been
made within the DoD and largely and by
the way I have a lot of affection and
respect for Anthony Principia as well
and I know his heart is in the right
place on this but I think we owe it to
our veterans not just to throw money out
there but to target that money to
serious people within the VA within the
private sector and some of our
universities who are prepared to work
with non government researchers to begin
to advance some of the ideas that are
beginning to to be developed dr. Hall
let me just get back to you what I heard
you say is that not a whole lot more is
happening in the UK is that your subject
that's correct so I think we face the
same sort of problems in the money
that's being spent is being utilized by
people who you may describe as being in
the employ of central government they
are simply government lackeys who
produce what the government wish to hear
to seems to be no independent research
going on or if there is it isn't
breaking through the press barrier to
get free publication
repeat the chairman has asked me when
you mention 92 people with identical
physical symptoms at a meeting how many
people were at the meeting 200 I wrote
down is that injury approximately 50,000
people deployed which 55 thousands of
reported symptoms 1500 or members of eng
vfa 200 at the AGM and of those two
hundred ninety two people who could take
my place and what does your government
say when you present them with this
information I have recent correspondence
from my prime minister decrying that
this syndrome exists and that's correct
as of two weeks ago denying what
decrying what was worth denying that
this syndrome exists my ill health
problems are officially denied so the
government the official position of the
governor's new players that does not
exist it is imaginary yet I have x-ray
proof I have MRI scans my blood
chemistry is deranged I'm now pre
leukemic that is not an imaginary
condition okay thank you very much mr.
chairman thank you thank you gentlemen
this time we'll go to